pas cette chanson pas cette chanson oh
non non non
voilà c'est cette époque-là jane quoi ce
salarié ne travaillait pas encore dans
l'établissement mais il fredonne
pourtant ses chansons en août 2005 et
que johnny hallyday tourner quelques
scènes du film jean philippe ici dans ce
pub voisins le bretonneux et aux
alentours
le chanteur à leurs acteurs donnait la
réplique à fabrice luchini
[Musique]
je vous suis
pourquoi moi
pourquoi tu m'as parlé c'est rejoindre
ma réalité et arrêter les conneries
sa raison j'ai toujours été tués
je suis johnny lors de ce tournage le
fils du gérant qui depuis a repris la
sphère familiale était présent on a pu
l'apercevoir jeudi parce que c'est vrai
qu'il était très entouré personne ne
pouvait le pouvait l'approcher et étant
donné qu'il a tourné sur le film à
l'extérieur abandonné la tengo c'est
qu'il a voulu aller aux toilettes est le
seul endroit pour aller aux toilettes
c'était de passer par le par le
restaurant donc nous on a pu rentrer
dans le restaurant et puis on a pu on a
pu voir johnny d'approché du coup à
prendre une
une petite une petite photo c'est le
seul moment où on a vraiment pu
l'approcher de près la photo de famille
à figure en bonne place dans
l'établissement pour le plaisir des
clients toujours un master d'anecdotes
luchini était ici au bar donc ils
rentrent dans le dans le bar et pour le
tournage du film
il boit un verre de whisky il faut
savoir que la bouteille de whisky était
plein au début du tournage qu'il n'en
fait d'assen 3,4 fois donc la bouteille
il a réellement vu jean philippe
imaginez la détresse d'un fan de johnny
perdu dans un monde parallèle où son
idole n'existait plus un monde devenu
aujourd'hui malheureusement bien réel